she's one of the most famous people in
the world
no not Rihanna it's Rihanna is it
Rihanna or Rihanna
I say Rihanna but Rihanna is still okay
and as of March 2023 the singer turned
entrepreneur is worth an estimated 1.4
billion dollars we reached out to
Rihanna's lawyer who declined to
participate lvmh and Rihanna's
Representatives did not respond to a
request for comment but here's what we
know about the business Empire that made
Rihanna one of the wealthiest musicians
in the world
Rihanna started releasing music in 2005.
since then she sold 60 million albums
and 215 million digital tracks worldwide
making her the top selling digital
artist of all time her tours have
generated over 290 million dollars in
revenue and she's dabbled in business
ventures for more than a decade she
launched multiple fragrances and
established brand Partnerships with Mac
cosmetics and Manolo Blahnik
in 2014 she was announced Puma's
creative director for women's products
and over the next few years the
company's sales Rose Puma attributed
that sales growth to its partnership
with Rihanna and now the singer's
business career is the primary source of
her wealth the bulk of it according to
Forbes is her reported 50 stake in Fenty
Beauty named after her own family name
Rihanna launched the Cosmetic sign in
2017 in collaboration with lvmh the
luxury conglomerate behind Brands like
Louis Vuitton and Dior it was widely
acclaimed as a success and stood out in
the market for launching with the
foundation offered in 40 Shades Rihanna
generated huge exposure for the line on
social media and lvmh which owns 50 of
Fenty beauty also owns Sephora which
carries Fenty beauty products in
thousands of stores around the world
Fenty Beauty made around 500 million
euro or roughly 570 million dollars in
sales in its first year according to
lvmh CEO Bernard Arno
as of August 2021 Forbes estimates Fenty
Beauty's value at 2.8 billion dollars
and sales have reportedly remained
strong according to lvmh Fenty Beauty
doubled its Revenue in 2022
Rihanna and lvmh also launched a fashion
line in 2019 but unlike Fenty Beauty
Fenty the fashion line didn't pan out
luxury fashion proved a harder Market to
crack than Cosmetics especially once the
pandemic hit lvmh paused production on
Fenty fashion in 2021 to focus on its
other Partnerships with Rihanna like
Fenty skin the skin care line launched
in 2020 lvmh hasn't shared much about
Fenty skin sales one report said the
brand made 30 million dollars in online
sales before it ever debuted in Sephora
Rihanna's other primary business is
Savage X Fenty a lingerie brand she
launched in 2018 with lvmh and other
investors she reportedly has a 30 stake
in the company Savage X Fenty products
are available in a wide range of sizes
to promote body positivity my mission is
just to have women all over the world
feel comfortable and sexy and have fun
with lingerie as of mid-2021 Forbes
estimated the company is worth 270
million dollars so even though Rihanna
hasn't released an album since 2016
she's made more than a billion dollars
in the past several years through her
other businesses
[Music]
Rihanna